Hello everyone. In this section,
we're going to be talking about differential privacy in the context of deep learning.
In this context, differential privacy is about ensuring
that when our neural networks are learning from sensitive data,
that they're only learning what they're supposed to learn from the data
without accidentally learning what they're not supposed to learn from the data.
Over this series of lessons and many projects which you'll be completing as we go,
we're going to walk through differential privacy from the early fundamentals
to one of the state-of-the-art methods for training
differentially private deep learning models.
The goal here is not just to give you an empirical ability to train a model using DP,
but also for you to understand the foundational principles of
differential privacy such as how noise is applied or how we define privacy.
What you want to be able to do with this is to be able to
speak intelligently about the subject to engineers,
scientists, and stakeholders and you want to be able to
continue to consume differential privacy research as it's produced.
That'll be the goal of this course. So let's jump in.